la région disputée du haut karabagh
toujours pas de répit dans les
affrontements entre les forces
arméniennes et azerbaïdjanaises alors
qu'elle diplomatie pour sortir de ce
conflit
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec gunnell safarova présidente de
l'association au dialogue france
azerbaïdjan bonsoir à vos côtés franck
papazian co président du ccas et le
conseil de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de france
bonsoir alors la france
on l'a dit affirme ce soir que la
turquie est impliquée militairement dans
ce conflit aux côtés de l'azerbaïdjan
que répondez-vous guisnel safarova cette
déclaration du ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian c'est la
turquie qui est à la base de ces
troubles
mais je pense que ça a été dit
clairement à plusieurs reprises par les
chefs d'état de l'azerbaijan de la
turquie et par rapport en fin par
d'autres officiels que l'azerbaïdjan et
la turquie
enfin la turquie rapportent un soutien
moral politique et diplomatique à
l'azerbaïdjan et dans aucun cas on
parlait de soutien militaire et donc il
n'y a rien pas d'un des militaires de la
turquie en azerbaïdjan d'une façon
d'azerbaïdjan n'a pas besoin des deux
militaires ni de la turquie n'est
d'autre payer car il a assez de deux
forces armées azerbaïdjanaises il ya
plus de cent mille personnes donc il un
pas une autre au dead
donc l'armée de l'azerbaïdjan il est
assez forte pour défendre et pour amener
le contrôle à offensive dans les
territoires de l'azerbaïdjan
franck papazian que répondez-vous à
lunel savard va justement sur cette
absence de militaires turcs en
azerbaïdjan selon un tunnel safarova
polichinelle aujourd'hui tout le monde
ne sait que le récit est stimulé
affaires de gamme de prix en la
république turque qui force qui stimule
qui
encourage l'azerbaïdjan à lancer des
offensives militaires depuis des années
contre l'arménie
on sait aujourd'hui que 400 djihadistes
des supplétifs à l'armée turque ont été
envoyés en azerbaïdjan on sait qu'il ya
105 ans experts militaires qui sont
allés à la manoeuvre à bakou pour
coordonner pour diriger la manoeuvre
militaire contre l'arménie
on sait que erdogan la nuit lui-même
nous sommes un seul peuple et deux états
erdogan a dit on va terminer le travail
donc effectivement l'implication de la
turquie au côté de l'azerbaïdjan ne fait
aucun doute
le gouvernement français l'oas et le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies a
reconnu que l'azerbaïdjan avait initié
cette attaque bombardé populations
civiles et les arméniens ne font que se
défendre face à une armée d'occupation
qui a pour objectif de massacrer les
aryens dur à la barre de prendre leur
al-ahmar et la turquie souhaite
également occupé le fût de l'arménie on
est dans le cadre d'un grand plan très
dangereux qui va mettre le feu aux
poudres de la région du caucase mais
aussi du moyen-orient et qui serait une
plaie pour le monde il faut absolument
arrêter l'azerbaïdjan il faut que
l'azerbaïdjan à rex et offensif
criminelle contre l'arménie qui ne le
vende callune en fait d'une halle
safarova on l'entendait et on constate
une escalade de violence inquiet qui est
dangereuse c'est indéniable menace pour
la stabilité de la région à ce que un
cessez-le-feu est possible selon vous on
sait qu'il ya une réunion de médiation
internationale sur la situation qui est
prévue qui a été annoncé à genève pour
jeudi
je voulais juste envie de rajouter une
chose que la serre voiture mais une
opération du contre offensive donc à
plusieurs reprises il avait les
provocations de la part de l'arménie
le premier ministre de l'arménie qu'est
déclaré les annonces dans les
territoires occupés de l'azerbaïdjan
clos et amélia points et il avait en
fait une investiture du chef de soi
disant république et celle de rue la
chocha après ils ont décidé de
transférer le
le parlement du soi-disant république à
choucha plusieurs familles arméniens du
liban qui étaient installés dans leur
haut karabagh y compris à choucha qui
est l'ancienne ville de l'azerbaïdjan ça
c'est une crime de guerre et cela est
totalement contraire de la convention de
genève il a les pattes roman historique
de l'azerbaïdjan qui efface et nos
monuments et stèles à tariq qui sont
détruits et l'azerbaïdjan est tellement
enfin l'azerbaïdjan il a il amène une
opération de contre offensive attendre
que il a il a enfin il a toujours
répondu ah enfin il a juste répondu à la
provocation
il se défend l'azerbaïdjan défends
simplement les intérêts il soutient sa
position et il mène donc à une messe à
politique et le tout le monde le monde a
tiré connaît le haut karabagh qu'on
faisant partie intégrante de
l'azerbaïdjan
toutes les organisations internationales
reconnaisse l'intégrité territoriale de
l'azerbaïdjan
tous les pays du monde et leur
reconnaisse l'intégrité territoriale de
l'azerbaïdjan et depuis presque trente
ans les résolutions de quatre
résolutions de l'onu à qui reste sur le
papier et depuis presque trente ans des
négociations sont menées dans le cadre
du groupe de minsk et qui est chaque
fois on fait régulièrement ils étaient
enfin l'armée ni les faux mails à des
provocations qui sont paralysés qui
paralyse et les profits seront va
écouter franck papazian qui va vous
répondre justement sur cette terre du
haut karabakh pour voiler historiquement
arménienne arménienne a été attribués à
staline par staline à l'azerbaïdjan en
1921 ce que madame oublie dire c'est
qu'à la fin des années 80 et au début
des années 90 en tête
l'azerbaïdjan a massacré d arménia kg
abad à choucha à mener la guerre contre
les arméniens et en 1994 un cessez le
feu est instauré sous des auspices du
groupe de minsk de loi et c'est eux et
depuis 1994 c'est bien depuis 26 ans
l'azerbaïdjan
violent si 1000 à 10000 fois par an le
cessez le feu en contravention à toutes
les normes de droit international en
elle a contracté une guerre la guerre
des quatre jours en mois de juillet le
12 juillet elle a agressé militairement
l'armée ni la république delà de
l'arménie donc est une république
reconnu par la communauté internationale
est là depuis le 27 septembre
elle mène des offensives de grande
envergure contre l'arménie dans le ce
laps de temps le peuple du karabakh ces
cons ces poteaux déterminé dans le cadre
d'un référendum d'autodétermination
ce peuple là ne retournera jamais ces
administrations de l'azerbaïdjan parce
que l'azerbaïdjan a massacré les
arméniens à la fin des années 80 et au
début des années 90
donc ça oubliez il n'en est pas question
les arméniens veulent vivre en paix
d'accord il azerbaïdjan est une menace
pour les arméniens nous quittâmes madame
devrait comprendre une chose c'est que
l'offensive actuelle est condamné par la
communauté internationale qui a reconnu
que l'azerbaïdjan était l'agresseur
laser belle jambe
bombardé des populations civiles les
arméniens de fonds ne font que se
défendre et il était important
aujourd'hui pour éviter des massacres
dans la région que la communauté
internationale prenne ses
responsabilités des négociations ou
demain à genève se poursuivre lundi à
moscou
et je pense qu'il est temps de faire
entendre raison à l'azerbaïdjan et à son
allié turbulent ça va embarrasser fait
chaud ken conditions pour un
cessez-le-feu aujourd'hui deux choses
les fameuses décision de 5 juillet 1921
et les il n'avait pas du tout il avait
il faut faire attention aux mots c'est
mais par attachement ni transfert
c'étaient les liens partant de nécessité
de la paix et les liens économiques
entre le karabagh supérieur et
intérieurs à inférieur et les liens
constat avec l'azerbaïdjan c'était
maintenir le haut karabagh en république
soviétique d'azerbaïdjan en lui
conférant une large autonomie régionale
maintenir il faut faire attention
nombreux qui ont utilisé mais par
attachement ni transfert ses mains
cette première chose d'eux mêmes on
parle par rapport au fait les cibles les
forces séparatistes
aidé par l'arménie actuellement cible
des installations et de son peuple et
qui se trouve en dehors voire très trop
loin de la zone
je peux parler de genji oeil qui est 105
kilomètres de laon il a même réseau qui
a à peu près à côté de capital à bas
coût et il va d une ironie et elle avait
parmi les blessés on trouve aussi en une
une arménien il perd en fait tu veux je
voulais juste préciser qu'il ya
actuellement trente mille arméniens qui
habite toujours en azerbaïdjan franck
papazian voilà sur le
le mot de la fin il reste
malheureusement que quelques secondes
franck papazian pour conclure qu est ce
qu il faudrait quelles conditions
aujourd'hui pour que finalement un
cessez-le-feu soit possible il faut que
l'azerbaïdjan comptes tels que le
karabakh n'est pas un territoire
azerbaïdjanais
c'est un territoire historique arméniens
qui a habité par des arméniens qui
veulent vivre en paix il faut laisser
les arméniens vivre en paix d'accord on
veut pas qu'on peut pas vivre un nouveau
génocide en 1920 comme nous l'avons vécu
en 1915
or les azerbaïdjanais sont des
agresseurs c'est un un état qui veut la
guerre et l'arménie veut la paix ça
suffit maintenant il faut votre discours
madame est incompréhensible et inaudible
c'est ce que tu es un gros grain si on
parle de la paix de lazard patineurs
vous voulez la paix et si vous parlez de
la gymnastique on peut parler de sujets
aussi de regarder qui était combien 1980
on va devoir le temps qui nous est
imparti se termine en tout cas merci à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté ce débat
dans ce contexte de grande tension
on le sait merci à vous d'une aile
safarova je rappelle que vous êtes
présidente de l'association au dialogue
france azerbaïdjan et merci à vous
franck papazian
je rappelle que vous êtes co président
du conseil de coordination des
organisations arméniennes de france